South Korea is hosting senior diplomats
from China and Japan for talks on
three-way cooperation Deputy foreign
ministers from three countries are
meeting in Seoul the talks are seen as
an attempt to ease beijing's concerns
over its neighbors growing defense ties
with Washington let's go to Florence
Louis who is live in Seoul for us
Florence what exactly are we expecting
from this meeting
well this is an attempt to revive a
trilateral summit that was first held in
2008 between leaders of South Korea
China and Japan but these Summits were
suspended in 2019 amid a dispute between
South Korea and Japan and also
subsequently because of the pandemic so
these talks on an attempt to try and
revive that Summit now this meeting in
Seoul comes also on the back of a
meeting between South Korean prime
minister Han daksu and Chinese president
Xi Jinping over the weekend in Hangzhou
on the sidelines of the Asian games now
analysts say this is an attempt to allay
concerns that Beijing may have over
Seoul drawing closer to Washington now
since president Yun sugil took power
last year he's drawn he's charted a
foreign policy course that was quite
different from his predecessors he had a
clear tilt in favor of the U.S we saw
him reinstating large-scale military
exercises with the US that had either
been downsized or suspended by the
previous administration now his
rationale was that Saul had to up its
military Readiness as a deterrence to
North Korea that had clared itself a
nuclear weapon state last year and has
been carrying out regular tests of
banned weapons but China sees these
military drills as a well as an attempt
to encircle it now that position never
really bothered the unit Administration
much but analysts say there has been a
slight change they're seeing a slight
change in tone and this could also be
explained perhaps by the fact that Seoul
is now concerned about Pyongyang drawing
closer to Moscow we've seen North Korean
leader Kim Jong-un visit Russia having
meetings with Vladimir Putin the Russian
president and with talks about closer
military cooperation between the two so
now we're seeing renewed efforts by the
union Administration to draw in China
into what president Yoon has described
as hoping to send out a message to rein
in the nuclear threat from North Korea
many thanks Florence Louis there for us
in Seoul